okay so the Kazushi pattern standing so
the pattern itself helps mine my feet my
weight shape shift my weight on my and
the resistance to boot in is what I used
to ground I ground okay and I want this
tilt so I'm here and we're going to do
the outward backward Kazushi pattern
with the Adibi hand here so you're not
going to use the format so I'm going to
round him and do it
boom we're just here if we get it all
technique you're gonna use your down if
you want but you'll be more skilled if
you can hit it with one hand
you see his body is going to tilt and
then I'm gonna read either leg clover
hold on immediately okay I'm bring the
other leg forward and then it's going to
come out this way so forget the
technique I'm going to get inspector
bring the other leg around it and then
okay let's charge includes that you're
not doing it what does the excess the
gas were surprised that your partner has
never been off okay but what's on
boundaries is
yeah the good coming down or the other
foot comes down
back then this is all no okay so he's
gonna laundry that foot forward but I
brought it back see that and then he's
gonna want to put that foot down but
we're not going that way so his foot
goes forward and then he wants to put
the foot down but that's not where its
head it's gonna be so the Kazushi angles
over here you see it goes that way he's
not gonna be able to do that so I don't
let him put his foot down his foot
that's telling you that you were going
straight down straight back no this
error I'm not grabbing him it's just
that I can't even
boom okay let's go
okay so so why my exercise is easier I'm
just changing my foot angle okay so
we're just here and now I'm giving it
some purpose
but in inside the spiral I can keep that
that tension I'm doing this with my feet
so if not this this not ending I'm doing
another cultivation take that step okay
try it again you want to but when you
take the step you generate my Kazushi
pattern you see it's when you take that
step then because you see this shiitakes
black hair do you see and then you want
to put it back and then it's over here
so your resistance is helping my
technique
okay okay so he's gonna push and I
drowned that drink this is energy this
this energy and I sent down he's going
to pull and I'm proud back to me
you see okay well I'm moving here this
is a push push and this is the pool
let's all on my feet
my feet aren't standing here alone with
just my heart his energy is in my feet
whoa whoa you got it because you're not
doing it you're just on top then you
have some magic formula okay no just
like yesterday's drill this move moves
on them on the right knee and this one
here is on the left you see that say you
have the power right knee boom boom
change the movement all right let's go
one so now we came to add the spiraling
geometry see and it'll help me what that
other part is the same so he's gonna
come around me and I'm going to be in
the back wall home safe
[Music]
athletic he knows he's supposed to go
over there and then yeah that was a lot
of my energy and I don't want him to
have that okay so we're not like when I
do the move but we're over here is I
don't want to be able to die okay on my
[Music]
right away that becomes my pivot point I
don't let him do that okay so you're
gonna feel compression and then I do
yeah so he's not he's not gonna walk
around me and then I do the first just
like here this part of the drill was
that foot gets pinned you see and that's
what allows him to do it on so the same
thing here there's an absorption and the
whole foot gets pinned and then boom up
but so if he tries to dive under it it
just works better because he picked
himself for you see that so but if I
don't have a pit and he dives under it
he's gone you see okay so you have now a
pressure on I thought you have to
understand what you're doing you have a
gravitational
all that leg and did you can use it as a
pivot point where his body can pivot
okay let's go on pin turn and just hand
comes in here is falling anyways right
so inside this curve there's a line
there has to be a eun-jung rule is it is
a free space where I do the technique
those of you that duck it out the bottom
you nothing like that hey so I the
throat was already happening on one huh
right so this just fits in there and
continues the kuzushi here is already
falling this is at a Meehan not at
throwing back I'm not going here here
and it was already quality is a 18 okay
so it's very effortless but you can see
that was the same and now I'm doing the
front inward put on the backside meaning
there's only two it's actually one okay
so pivot thread here you go
okay let's go throw happen with the hand
okay so Y at Y in turn
well I'm not going here and then
shutting his body in that sometime and
when I bring the front inward position
what I'm going to do is take this full
body and pick it up that's my dog my job
with that that hand is not to continue
the division my job is to deconstruct
the entire equilibrium his his base of
support his line of gravity his center
of gravity III in the regular kuzushi
pattern it was me moon maneuvering this
line and gravity continually out of his
base of support
okay but very athletic people even
though his foot and his resistance is
set me up people I'd let it keep get her
on now okay so what your IQ toe is doing
is he starts out with line of gravity
and then but this whole once I do this
and I do the triangle OBD be knocking a
wedge now takes over the X pattern and
this whole thing gets displaced very
much like Gideon took the two swords
cannot operate the same space so one
hits this place together that's my job
my job is not to throw him why my job is
et me is to displace him with muck with
me okay so same technique will displace
what's what's different different is
here so you said you do Nittany kill -
so you're doing each job right and
they're not gonna keep rolling them
forward taking this line and drop it out
I'm gonna do another DVD wedge here I'm
not doing it Goma
whoa winch pull so I don't my board just
pop this integrity and boom from sector
off the back foot create a wedge and you
can't be standing there and because his
lying around he was going out
she can't can't be gaining put his face
pork back underneath you will not do
that if you keep yourself another agenda
you